[Music]
a school district in utah recently
decided to suspend
their reading program after a third
grade teacher read her class a book
about a transgender child they suspended
the program
rather than let their children read a
book about a transgender
kid i couldn't believe it now normally i
would spend five minutes on my show
railing about how the people who decided
to do that are complete garbage but
i'm having a nice week so i'm feeling
patient enough to try to talk to the
people who are scared
to let their children learn about
transgender equality i'm not sure how
it'll go but
i'm going to try in a segment called
look at it this way
[Music]
hey hi there um i hear you don't want
your
kids reading the story of a little
transgender child
okay well um that's really stupid
okay okay that didn't work but uh how
about this how about this
the world is changing and it's scary huh
okay yeah when people say things like
pronouns and
gender binary it feels scary doesn't it
okay that's better well if a pronoun can
scare you
then maybe you should stay yo dumbass at
home
sorry sorry okay okay wait let me try
again uh look at it this way
i know the world is changing isn't it
yeah
but that's no reason to deny your
children facts about the world
the fact is their world has transgender
people in it doesn't it
yeah look i know you may think that
it'll turn your child
transgender but buddy if they are they
already are and
as powerful as this book is it can't
make a child something they're not
and when what's going to happen next
semester when you find out one of your
kids schoolmates is trans
hypothetically hypothetically
hypothetically what will you do then
right your kid will be all like why did
no one tell me this was a possibility
huh i mean hey your idiot child thinks
paw patrol is real but not that
transgender people exist i mean
what are you raising them to be
professionally dumb oh sorry
sorry i take it back i take it back okay
hey look at it like this
whether you know it or not transgender
people exist
you're not helping your kid by sending
them out into the world unprepared
it would be like you never told them
about birds they're gonna see one and be
like
i wish someone had the balls to teach me
about birds because they're so beautiful
and
they make my world a better place but
you won't and then
we have to deal with your dumb ass
offspring the transgender community
suffers workplace discrimination crap
health care violence at an alarming rate
and
they got to deal with your dumb ass kids
too
sorry okay wait wait wait wait okay um
look at it this way the world can be a
great place to live
if you're willing to fill it with love
and it is
with love that i'd like to say please
for the sake of humanity
teach your children that it's okay to be
different can you do that
great idiot
[Music]
you